oui tout investissement schumi yes we
shall sdb yes alaric termine ici pas
d'exercice contraignant ni de grandes
conversations pour apprendre l'anglais
tout passe par le jeu et les activités
de groupes après année chez mini schools
ses enfants connaissent déjà quelques
mois ces dames la hyène elephant man qui
met en ligne
oasis karman à bangui âgés de 5 à 7 en
lan à alaric et youssef retrouve
clémence chaque semaine pendant une
heure l'animatrice au sein de
l'association elle s'appuie sur des
visuels des comptines ou des objets
colorés pour enrichir leur vocabulaire
mini schools ils ont une façon de faire
qui est assez particulière c'est à dire
qu'il part du principe que on apprend en
s'amusant
un caillou cannes open your eyes on a
l'impression qu'ils se rendent pas
compte que
c'est un apprentissage pour eux c'est
juste des jeux et puis après ils ont il
réalise qu'en fait ça peut être utile
c'est une association qui existe depuis
plus de 45 ans qui a été créé par une
maman qui voulait faire apprendre
l'anglais à ses enfants
plus tôt ils apprennent mieux il se
forme l'oreille géré par montigny faune
english l'association existe depuis 40
ans à montigny le bretonneux chaque
année 90 enfants apprennent à
communiquer dans la langue de
shakespeare
les cours reprendront à la rentrée
gauthier dr faye ce qu'est ce
ok